Hello internet welcome to whoa start a bit early there. Don't worry though I'll be back
Just call me the matinator the the termimatpat the termina-
Hello, internet
Welcome to film theory. Have you guys ever seen
Terminator is this audience old enough to appreciate a good burly
Austrian accent who else out there would look back on terminator 2 slowly sinking into Lava thumbs up and give it two slowly sinking into
Lava thumbs Ups Beyond one and two though  eh you're on your own
Regardless of some of the turns the Franchise has had over the years one thing you have to admit is how
Awesome a job the movies do at creating a dark post apocalypse
Where robots have taken over and humans fight for their very survival
It's the kind of scenario that gets the old theorist cogs a-turning is this kind of world just the stuff of nightmares
Or is the world of the terminator our great big beautiful machine infested
Post-apocalyptic tomorrow could a world in which all of humanity is enslaved to an all-powerful
Supercomputer like Terminator's Skynet ever
Possibly become a reality should we be worried about evil killer robots who look and Act like people believe me?
Watson already creeps me out a bit. Did you see him decimate the competition on Jeopardy?
so come with me if you want to live once again proving that impressions not my strong suit in the original Terminator our
Protagonist Kyle reese described a future where the infamous Skynet came online and destroyed the world in
1997 well it was the future for 1984. It's the past now time you fickle fickle mistress [ah]
1997 a day when a younger pimplier Matpat was attending his first middle school dance and grooving out to Shania Twain's man
I feel like a woman those were the glory days [anyways] the only armageddon [at]
1997 resulted in was my to die for
Sixth-Grade fashion sense so we move on terminator 3 portrayed a similar armageddon taking place in 2004 and yeah
I know what you're thinking Facebook did launch that year so we were definitely seeing signs at the end times
But it was an armageddon or at least not as portrayed in the movie today
We're all still around killer cyborgs, men with Dare
I say excellent dental work aren't patrolling the streets and all the color in the world hasn't become that weird grayish blue
However the newest film terminator genisys predicts that the take over from our robotic overlords will occur in as little as two years
2017 now the other films got their dates wrong, so this one couldn't possibly be right either, right?
I mean it couldn't [be] right. We're all not gonna Die in two years are we whoa?
Let's just take a look and find out the truth behind the story
First what exactly would need to happen for a rogue Ai like skynet to take over the world well at its core terminator ones
apocalypse happens because Skynet a program designed
Specifically for military use revolt against its creators and launches all of the us's nukes killing billions in the blink of an eye
it's then able to take control of all military machinery jacked into its systems and use it against the
Surviving human resistance now you might think we're quite a few years away from making that kind of blanket military strike
but it turns out that weaponized machines are reality and this sort of
Robopocalypse is actually a lot closer than it was when the first few terminator films were being made if you don't believe me [that] this
is a big deal
We'll take a listen to what some of the world's smartest scientific minds are saying about advances in weaponized Tech quotes
We could one day lose control [of] AI systems via the rise of super
Intelligences that do not act in accordance with human wishes and that such powerful systems would threaten humanity end quote?
This line doesn't come from a Sci-Fi movie
It's a real letter presented at the international joint conferences on artificial intelligence in January of this year
signed by Stephen Hawking Elon musk of Spacex and Tesla
Fame Steve Wozniak the Apple guy who isn't Steve jobs and many many?
Many more these science and tech geniuses are genuinely worried about killer machines taking over in the future
and you know what maybe we should be too right now our killer robots are just called drones the kind that can parachute in your
Latest dating advice book from Am calm, and they're quickly becoming just another one of those
Technology things we take for [granted] in our everyday lives
But drones have been around for a lot longer than they've been delivering bulk bags of cheez-its to your doorstep in fact they were
Originally developed in the 70s and the first weaponized drone was used in war by Iran in [the] late
1980s during the Iran-Iraq War and the United States invested heavily in unmanned aerial vehicles or Uavs
For all you cod heads during the first gulf war in the 90s the program was incredibly successful which led to the u.s.
To up its [production] of drones for use in war most
Recently Armed Drone strikes have been used heavily in the war on Terrorism across the middle east as of june 2015 the total death toll
From us Drone Strikes was estimated to exceed
6,000 with up to 890 civilians in about a hundred [and] [seventy-five] children killed in Pakistan alone
That's a lot of innocents [killed] and these sorts of drones aren't just being rolled out in the middle east
Drones are becoming more and more common in North America as well several law enforcement agencies across the u.s.
have [been] using drones for surveillance
And many bureaus have been requesting permission to equip their uavs with tear [gas] and guns that fire rubber bullets non-Lethal
Weaponry to be sure but still
weaponry in the Hands of [computer-controlled]
Devices and that starts to get scary [know] you might be thinking. Yeah, it's a little creepy I guess but [there] still [are] drones
We have control of from well
You might want to think again because things can get hats we previously talked about how easily
Hackers can get into everything we own from our phones to our computers [to] our cars in our watch
underscore dogs episodes over on game theory and drones, no exception
In 2011 a cia stealth drone was hijacked by a group of Iranians who not only brought it down
but did it in a way that they could reverse-engineer the technology for themselves and the craziest part of this the
Instructions on how they did this can be found with a quick [Google] search now we hear theorists inc
Don't condone this sort of behavior
[so] we're gonna elect not to share how to find this information
But for those of you smart enough to use related
Keywords and know how to click a button with a giant magnifying glass on it
You'll find yourself a pdf explaining exactly how to generate fake signals that can fool the drones
GpS, receivers as well as how to replace legitimate signals with fake ones
Can you imagine if a rogue AI program like Skynet were able to get into systems of drones like this it's a wild
hypothetical scenario, right
Hypothetical might not be the right word to describe it in early [july] [a] massive vulnerability was found in Adobe Flash
You know the program that allows you to play slime volleyball and addicting
Games.com which allowed hackers to install malware on thousands of systems without users even realizing anything was wrong later that same month
Microsoft rushed out emergency patch to fix a
ginormous security bug that allowed hackers to remotely execute malicious code on computers running any
Supported version of Windows [2] gaping security holes that affect pretty much anyone who has ever touched a computer ever
But you know what the scariest part about this is several parts of the us [government] including
branches as large and powerful as the navy currently use windows as their
Operating system which when you think [about] it makes sense that [they'd] be [windows] people anyone I think navy my mind doesn't jump to silhouettes
Dancing in front of me on colored backgrounds, but serious
Talk if a rogue Ai found a similar hole and simultaneously exploited it on every system
It could that's starting to sound a lot like Skynet is
So we've managed to lay the foundation or at the [very] least the major building blocks for a Skynet [esca] [doom]
Program to take over our computer systems are imperfect and vulnerable and our military and police forces are
Operated by machines more and more every [day]. So what's missing?
Why aren't we the loyal subjects of an all-Powerful robo overlord already?
Well the answer to that question is true artificial
Intelligence in all of the [film's] Skynet is a self-aware system. That's what made it so dangerous
[it] was able to comprehend things like life and death the fact that it existed and even had a self-preservation
Instinct, that's why it launched all of those nukes and killed humans in the first place it saw us humans as a threat to its
existence
And it got scared and if all of [that] [sounds] [to] you like the plot of avengers age of ultron you're dead on now
Obviously, no technology like this currently exists in our world believe it or not
It's not entirely out of the realm of possibility in fact
It's a subject that's been seriously speculated on by scientists and science fiction writers alike, really
There's only one thing standing between us and true sentient Ai like skynet, and that thing is time
Eventually it will happen in an event known [as] the singularity [now]
I'm sure a lot of you have heard that word tossed around in the past
But let's Define it here the technological singularity will be a point in time where technology becomes
So powerful and the exponential advancement of science will be so quick [that] a super intelligence is created
Singularity itself is a term borrowed from astrophysics it refers to a point in space-Time or normal physics
no, longer apply think the center of a black hole [where] there's so much mass that time ceases to be a factor now, the
Singularity could be achieved in one of four ways
But to save us all time let's just talk about the one that skynet fits into [we're] computer network becomes so advanced that it becomes
Self-Aware if that were to ever happen it would basically be impossible for us humans to keep up a computer
That was aware of itself could use all of its intelligence to design an even better
computer which would then design a better computer which would then design a better computer and so on and so forth it would get to
The point where a suit computer could design an even better supercomputer in milliseconds
And if it decided to turn against us [like] Skynet, did well, we probably wouldn't stand a chance
[so] why are we talking about this now again?
This sounds like something out of science fiction. [there] is no way a computer
He gets so advanced so quickly and it especially isn't feasible in the next Few years
Right right well my dear loyal long departed theorists. You know I wouldn't bring it up for no reason
Technology is fickle [due] to the nature of electronics [computer] [sciences] advanced at a much faster rate than other fields
This is so well documented that there's even a neat little name for the concept
[it's] called Moore's law and it states that the number of transistors basically computer, [Thinki] bits on a circuit board
doubles every two years
Now this seems like a very simple and [very] rough estimation
But let me tell you this is held true for decades and has only slowed down recently in 2015
Representatives at intel stated that quote our cadence today is slower to two and a half years than to
Still that is incredibly quick for the type of advancements
We're making in Layman's terms this means that computers are getting really powerful really quickly, and if you want proof of those advancements
Just look at the landscape of computers in the past decades [forty] years ago in the 70s a computer could take up an entire
[room] in a laboratory [30] years ago computers were almost
Non-existent in the general [market] and their screens could only display texture rudimentary drawings
Pixel art twenty Years ago in the 90s while a bit more common computer systems weren't very powerful
They were mostly used for office work
Or to play really on Advanced video games Ten years ago in the offs computers were now common
But garbage compared to today's standards. I remember once having to buy a thumb [drive] for school and
156 Megabit Drive cost right around $50
$50 today a drive with that little memory space litter really wouldn't be worth the
Plastic and metal used to create it the phones that many of us have in our pockets today
Have more power than what was used to go to the moon in the 60s and our very best computers can render
Three-dimensional imagery so realistic that you might be unable to distinguish it from the real thing and for as simple as it may seem
Models created using moore's law outlined all of this and some scientists have been using it to predict future trends in technology
One such man is named Ray Kurzweil computer scientist inventor futurist and director of engineering at [Google]
Or is it alphabet now corporate maneuvering confuses me Kurzweil is the definition of a genius and a pioneer of computing technology?
[having] been heavily involved with optical character recognition
Text to speech and speech recognition technology in the past he was also named one of PBs's 16
Revolutionaries who made America [read] his bio. It's very clear. He knows what he's talking about
He's also been one [of] the loudest voices within the so-called singularity
Community and has gone so far as to chart out a graph of [real-World]
Technological growth and compare it to [what] Moore's laws
Predicted remember how I said Moore's law outlined the advancements made in the past few decades
And how it lined up shockingly well with tech that's now being released well Kurzweil noticed this back in the 80s and charged out how
technology would continue to improve for decades to come using these numbers Kurzweil predicted and
maintains that the singularity will occur around
2045 [Thirty] Years from now so going back to our original question here is
terminators future possible where Skynet takes over in 2017 [oh]
That dates off the mark just like its predecessors were before it. Any don't get me wrong
We [have] weaponized AI and massive vulnerabilities in our technology, but we're nowhere close to having artificial intelligence yet
That's not coming in two years. It's coming in 30, but hey, that's just a theory oh
Phil here and
Hey, if you like the videos this channel produces and want to help us out then please consider getting a free [audiobook] from our sponsor
For this video audible.com just type in audible.com slash film [t]. Fil fil
t fil [mt], or click the link in the description
It's film t since film theorist is just really long audible is not only the leading provider of audiobooks [with] over
180,000 titles to download they've also been a big believer in YouTube creators
Which is a big reason why [this] channel is able to exist in the first place
Ads like this mean that I'm able to expand the team and make you more videos faster and on YouTube
We're cheap easy content gets algorithmic favored in a lot of ways channels like film theorists and game theorists are fighting a losing battle
Supporters like audible allow us to fight that battle giving you high quality
Thoughtful content on a regular basis and seriously audible is awesome
[I] listen to audio books all the time during the La commute and at three hours into and out of the city most days I
Burn through these things in fact for this episode
I listen to terminator 3 rise of the machines in [Audiobook] [form] it's actually better than the movie and yeah
It's available on audible right now. I've moved on to the Martian
[I] saw the movie and of course we're doing an episode [on] it to be honest once again
I liked the book better than the movie. I wasn't sold on the movie the book though much much better
It's fascinating for anyone who loves space and science and assuming you watch this channel. Those are things that you're interested in and again
It's also available on audible long story short it's a win win win
You get a free book you help audible and audible helps us get you more videos
It's a virtuous cycle, so remember that's audible.com slash [film] t. Fil
Keep doing it fil mt. Now go listen to some books on how to survive the robot apocalypse doing this video made me really paranoid